bonjour christophe ventura merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
comment expliquer l'intensité de ces
manifestations plus d'un an après le
début du mouvement il ya deux jours du
référendum pour changer la constitution
ait eu de violentes manifestations
avant-hier je crois que l'arrivée enfin
l'impact de la pandémie de communes 19 a
finalement un peu fait oublier la
puissance de ce mouvement populaire au
chili qui était tout simplement
historique
lui aussi puisque jamais le pays avait
connu de telle mobilisation sociale avec
une variété de revendications et
d'exigence vraiment d'abord social
contre la vie chère les inégalités il
faut toujours rappeler que le chili est
l'un des pays les plus inégalitaires en
tout et que cette constitution
d'ailleurs c'est un peu la construction
des inégalités au chili puisqu'elle
graver dans le marbre un modèle
économique qui est celui du
néolibéralisme et qui fait passer sous
les fourches caudines des politiques
libérales orthodoxe de chicago et bien
ce qu'ont dit les gens vous avez
interviewé c'est à dire l'éducation la
santé les services publics en général
les ressources naturelles tout sens à
tout ça étant largement dédié qu'on
s'est pas laissée au secteur privé à la
privatisation dans ce pays donc ce
mouvement social
il a explosé contre tout ça est donc ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui était un peu
attendu puisque c'est pas parce que la
pandémie est venu momentanément
finalement m confiné les sens et de la
population chilienne tous ces millions
de gens qui ont manifesté depuis des
mois à l'automne et l'hiver dernier en
payant le prix parfois du sang comme on
l'a vu et bien tous ces gens là sont là
aussi pour rappeler que cette ce
référendum qui va avoir une aujourd'hui
est une concession qui l'ont arraché à
un gouvernement qui était dos au mur
face à la puissance de son mouvement et
que les allées sondages à la veille de
cette consultation qu'aucune heures pas
les sondages en fait l'enjeu du son de
cette course de ce vote aujourd'hui
d'abord c'est de connaître l'ampleur du
résultat effectivement alors et de la
participation c'est ça qui va être très
important il y aura des stratégies
différentes
les sondages aujourd'hui 10 grosso modo
que le oui au changement de constitution
devrait être approuvée par 70 à 75% des
chiliens qui s'exprime aujourd'hui donc
l'ampleur du vote finalement viendra si
c'est oui confirmer si vous voulez
l'adéquation entre ce mouvement
populaire et puis la grande masse de
l'opinion que beat chilienne il va
falloir l'autre côté calculé
l'abstention parce que c'est plutôt la
droite et le centre droit qui a été
obligé de concéder comme je disais ce
référendum qui ne veut pas le nom le
rejet de la réforme de la constitution
est plutôt centre droite et à droite et
donc une bonne partie de cet électorat
là pourraient aussi s'abstenir pour ne
pas participer à la légitimation de ce
processus qui va ouvrir le chemin
politique tout à fait nouveau historique
effectivement dans ce pays que dit cette
nouvelle constitution si elle est
adoptée assemblée constituante ou
assemblée constituante mixte au final
quel est le réel changement et qu'est ce
que ça implique concrètement alors pour
l'instant on peut pas répondre à cette
question c'est pas du tout ce que ma
contenir la nouvelle constitution parce
que si aujourd'hui les chiliens vote
pour le principe d'en changer
ensuite il ya tout un processus qui se
met en place alors effectivement ce
qu'on appelle l'assemblée mixte c'est
quoi l'assemblée mixte est à dire les
chiliens vont voter désigner des députés
spécifiquement disons élus pour préparer
un nouveau texte de constitution il ne
gérons pas les affaires courantes ils
vont préparer ce nouveau texte mais
l'assemblée mix de dire et ça c'est ce
qu'a voulu gouvernement pour limiter
finalement le le processus c'est qu' il
n'y a qu'une moitié des constitutions
qui soit élu directement par le peuple
et une autre moitié qui soit constitué
de deux parlementaires actuels ce qui
laisse aux parlementaires la possibilité
de limiter voire de bloquer d'avoir un
droit de veto sur certaines propositions
qui pourraient émaner de députés eux
issus directement de la population et
l'autre option c'est assez scandaleux un
résultat aujourd'hui c'est banos on veut
une constituante qui soit constituée que
de députés constituants exclusivement
issu d'un vote populaire et donc ce qui
écarte
participation des parlementaires et des
partis politiques actuellement disons au
sein d'à présent au sein du congrès
chilien donc là une constitution qui
serait 100% avec des constitution issue
du vote populaire pourrait ouvrir dix
ont des propositions plus radicale plus
entière sur la réforme politique
économique souhaitée par les chiliens et
donc on va avoir cette deuxième angers
du vote d'aujourd'hui de savoir quel va
être là là là là disons là comment va
être constitués finalement cette
assemblée constituante
justement sur le résultat qu'est ce que
ça peut donner
la contestation populaire à ce qu'elle
peut repartir de plus belle ce qu'elle
peut retomber en intensité et écoute du
président conservateur sebastian pinera
et peut sortir affaibli renforcer alors
selon le résultat selon qu'on a un
résultat que soient massivement oui au
changement de constitution est
massivement oui pour une assemblée
entièrement issue du vote populaire
le président pinera sera effectivement
affaibli parce que son camp est divisé
sur ce référendum
la partie la plus modérée de la droite
le concept parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
choix comme j'expliquais au début de
l'entretien mais une bonne partie de la
droite dure voire d'extrême droite en
particulier autour de musique s'appelle
caste va faire campagne pour le non
francs à sept changements de
constitution
et si le oui l'emporté massivement la
droite sera divisé pour la suite si le
résultat est plus tempéré que par
exemple les chiliens vote pour une
assemblée qui mélange disons des élus
populaire et puis des dirigeants des
partis actuels au congrès et donc la
majorité conservatrice puisqu'ils ont la
majorité alors la droite sera moins
diviser c'est ça c'est ça qui va être un
scénario et puis pour la gauche
la situation sera pas simple non plus
parce que la gauche qu'est devra elle
aussi finalement savoir si elle va
épouser la puissance et la radicalité du
mouvement populaire ou si elle va
chercher aussi à modéré certaines
propositions dans les débats de la
concision qui se tiendront entre après
le vote et avril 2021 lorsque avril 2021
étant la date de l'élection de cette
assemblée constituante qui aura un euro
pour préparer le texte et le soumettre
de nouveau référendum
du pays pour que la nouvelle
constitution soit le cas échéant adopter
donc le processus est complexe et on va
avoir toute façon c'est très clair un
mouvement populaire qui va continuer de
faire entendre sa voir au milieu d'une
pandémie qu'il faut le rappeler est
toujours très puissante au chili comme
ailleurs en amérique latine puisque ce
vote aujourd'hui va se dérouler pendant
la pandémie dans tout ça nous donne des
éléments qui montrent un chemin complexe
un peu indéterminée mais qui en tout cas
ouvre un disons un espace démocratique
très très fort et souveraineté populaire
qui était pas du tout programmé au chili
encore moins par les armements
merci christophe ventura d'avoir répondu
à nos questions on rappelle que vous
êtes directeur de recherche à l'iris
institut des relations internationales
et stratégiques vous êtes évidemment
spécialiste de l'amérique latine